aber freunde herzlich willkommen hier
heute zurück zu einer weiteren episode
gott beschütze spielt auf dem kompletten
planeten genau das denke ich mir auch
gerade ganz ganz viele von euch haben
sich mal wieder gott simulator hier auf
meinem kanal gewünscht ach ich richtig
jeder der es den helm auf jeder von euch
wollen wir wieder gesehen deswegen gehen
wir direkt auf unseren duell villa und
das sieht auf jeden fall richtig
professionell aus
wie erfährt man dann noch mal mit dieser
scheiße kingsley der und auf einmal
brennt einfach jemand ich liebe dieses
spiel wer jetzt kein scheiß ich muss
doch eher drücken damit ich doch darauf
okay jetzt kann ich jetzt kann nicht
fahren sehr gut von nein nein ich bin
sehr gut in diesem spielen falls der
eine oder andere unter euch komplett
verarscht als wenn ich nicht mal so
einen kleinen hügel hoch fahren kann
falls der eine oder andere das spiel gar
nicht kennen sollte ein dicker diese
steuerung ist somit das kann doch nicht
wahr sein
er war einfach los alter wir laufen wir
zu fuß
das hier ist das spiel gut simulieren
wir spielen diese kleine ziege ich hoffe
dass jeder gleich erkennen sollte und
dass sie jetzt immer noch diese waste of
space map in der wir im weltraum sind
wir können auch mal mit sonnendeck glaub
ich
i'm sorry ich wollte damit eigentlich
nur fahren keine ahnung was ich hier
jetzt wieder kaputt gemacht habe aber
die teile sehen nicht mehr fahrbereit
aus dass sie jetzt auf jeden fall immer
noch diese emotion ace of spades web wo
wir im weltraum sind
das sitzt die erde da wohnen wir
es gibt ja auf jeden fall noch ganz ganz
viele dinge zu entdecken die wir einfach
noch und ich weiß nicht was die mission
von diesem scheiß ziegen dings ist ich
will hier einfach nur normal rumlaufen
das hallo wie gehts hier
wir haben auf jeden fall in der letzten
folge die ja schon wirklich den fast ein
halbes jahr her ist meine ich an haben
wir diesen raum hier entdeckers hier ist
der eingang ins research center
hier sind wir letztmals schon
rumgelaufen an verschiedenen schwachsinn
gemacht heute möchte ich mit euch
irgendwo anders hingehen
das heißt wir schauen uns jetzt mal hier
ein bisschen weiter drin um in diesem
ganzen gebiet um das ist ja riesig also
die web ist glaube ich die größe ist
bisher jeden gautschi militär gab also
das sind glaube ich so heiß
wasserquellen oder irgendwie sowas keine
ahnung was das soll
hier geht irgendwie so ein ding hallo
sie gelände mal bitte da neben den
kisten denn in diesen kisten ist geld
drin und was ist jetzt passiert
wir haben neuen freigeschaltet ab hin da
ich habe keine ahnung wo dieses money
bin sein soll
wenn wir hier mal reingehen wird mir
glaube ich auch erst wieder bei den helm
abgenommen genau deppen weil man hier
rein
das hier ist diverse moment versteht da
oben das ist die kommando bridge ich hab
mein gott was ist denn bruder was ist
denn mit dir falsch frist der gras ich
mein hobby suchen auf jeden fall weiter
dass manni bin was das hier vor hallo
hier haben wir noch ein bisschen geld
ist weg
moodys com mit zdk jetzt fliegt der
juden in der luft roboter was je mehr
gegenstände man findet je mehr kisten
mann eröffnet desto mehr eröffnet man
sich hier die welt alexis die night okay
da hinten kommen ich anscheinend noch
nicht rein aber wir suchen wir weiter da
ist die library also die bücherei hier
vorne also noch weitere von diesem
komischen sachen da ist wieder die
bücherei hier sind der haut einfach auf
einer palette holz rum viel spaß unter
den kisten unten ist irgendwie yogakurs
oder so was also sie zumindest nach
irgend sondertrainings dings auf
was macht ihr geht das hier sind nur so
pappfiguren das sind träger was ist der
sinn gesucht doch einfach nur dieses
komische money bin ich heute mal mich
mal hier drauf und es liegt man hier
hoch vielleicht will ich das ja von hier
oben
ich habe diese map ist so fucking groß
die nehmen wir erst mal noch die kisten
mit weil die genau hier sind ist halt
das ganze geld drin was wir brauchen
irgendwelche neuen sachen freizuschalten
hier ist was soll ich da mal reingehen
hallo freunde was macht dir ich habe mal
wieder überhaupt keine ahnung was hier
abgeht wenn ich hier raus gehe bin ich
auf der anderen seite united states of
america also dass sich irgendeine ranch
auf der ich gerade bin
die normale web von uns ist ich habe
keine ahnung ich habe wirklich ich habe
absolut keine ahnung wo ich gerade bin
ich klettere jemand eben die steine hoch
und da sehen wir auch schon dass ich
nicht das hier ist glaube ich unsere
normale web keine ahnung wie ich dann
jetzt auf diese range gekommen bin
man gibt aber egal freunde wir schauen
uns immer um neue leute habt ihr diese
demo jetzt ist er komplett verschwunden
egal mehr essen für mich was haben die
denn hier gegessen da die brot das hier
ist bio brot kommt nehmen wir das brot
mit ich weiß trotzdem immer noch nicht
wie ich hierhin gekommen bin hatte ziege
kannst du mir sagen wo ich bin ich lasse
auch das brötchen zu essen da ist das
brot da nicht da da komme ich auf jeden
fall also von sunny super-star gates
also irgendein suppen laden und was
machst du siegen verboten was wenn ich
hier drauf gehe das willst machen
überhaupt keinen plan was ich machen
soll
da stand ihnen gerne aufgaben nein nein
nein ich kann leute ich fliege durch den
weltraum oh mein gott ich kann ich kann
mein gott immer mit der ruhe
okay das ganze mal kurz festhalten ich
fliege gerade durch den weltraum
als ziege mit einem helm auf wir
entfernen uns auf jeden fall immer
weiter von der ranch da hinten
ich weiß nicht was das hier oben ist das
ist eine galaxy pizza freunde ich bin
gerade wirklich sehr sehr verwirrt ich
habe überhaupt keinen plan was weder
mein gott jetzt korrigieren wir mit dem
mit dem pizza dings holt er to be back
to the station also ich halte jetzt noch
her gedrückt und dann bin ich eigentlich
war das heutige ziel dieses manni binz
zu finden jetzt ist eine kuh aus
styropor kann ich die mitnehmen kommt da
nämlich die kurzwahl mit ein paar
sekunden später vergab kommt die kunden
jetzt hier gerade diese range dieses
lake of america heißt es er glaube ich
kommt wo wir ihn jetzt mal hier vorne
lang schauen uns das hier machen hier
ist auf jeden fall nichts an was ist das
es ist ein google muss leider weg ich
hab eine neue kuh gefunden also wir
haben jetzt hier diese komische kuh und
können jetzt mit der kuh hier
irgendwelche abenteuer erleben
die sieht halt nicht so gesund aus
irgendwie keine ahnung was mit der
abgeht wir sind immer noch auf der suche
nach diesem mann event kann ich jetzt
mit der coolen den weltraum fielen in
slate ich sage gar nichts mehr
feind wenn china also wir sollen dem
besitzer dieser range hier anscheinend
finden das ist unsere aufgabe
ich habe allerdings überhaupt keine
ahnung wo ich da irgendwie anfangen soll
den zu suchen oder wo hier die ich mein
management gut
ich glaub audi partner eingeklemmte
hätten die haut major league soccer
please help me find das sind meine
antwortmöglichkeiten niemals independent
jetzt habe ich auch eine mission oder
war es egal ich lecke ihn die ganze zeit
an und dann nach einer gewissen zeit
heute einfach wieder auf sie zu lecken
und dieser gaal liegt läuft weg kommt
hier ich drücke ich lag ihnen und die
zunge ist wieder weg das ist eine
scheiße da selbst wieder einpacken die
verschwinden von hier freunde ich habe
keinen bock mehr auf dieses united
states of america oder was auch immer
ist ich will zurückgehen
eine komische welt hier genau da sind
wir wieder und ich will diese blöde
money bin finden statt was wir heute
freigeschaltet haben meine einzige
mission heute war
zu diesem manni binz zu kommen und das
einzige was ich sehe es dieses kraut
kicker und keine ahnung was hier unten
kann ich irgendwie langlaufen das ist
noch komplett verschlossen
wir haben was neues freigeschaltet und
zwar testing wir haben wir haben das
gerade frei geschaltet das heißt wir
können jetzt hier oben einfach mal rein
gehen denn dieses test stemmers jetzt
wird uns wahrscheinlich wieder der helm
abgenommen
genau und jetzt öffnet sich die tür und
jetzt könnt ihr hier rein und jetzt bin
ich in irgend einem testgelände glaube
ich kommen werden dafür ausgestellt also
ich hab keine ahnung was ihr auch hier
machen soll da sind auch wieder irgend
welche für die ausgestellt werden
hier steht eine kuh das erinnert mich
gerade ein bisschen an portal allerdings
würde ich sagen dass wir das alles in
der nächsten folge von golf simulator
machen werden meine lieben freunde ganz
ganz viele von euch meinen einfach unter
meinen letzten videos in den kommentaren
luca waren lädst du endlich mal wieder
drei meter hoch hier
dort ist sie geworden daher wenn euch
das heutige video hier gefallen hat dann
das gerne einen daumen hoch unter diesem
video ihr da schreibt mir und in die
kommentare ob ich eventuell nächste
woche noch mal gut sieben meter hoch
laden soll weil die map ist riesig und
ich habe auch noch gesehen dass es von
gott simulierter zombie edition gibt
also wenn ich das noch mal irgendwie
spielen soll dann schreibt uns in den
kommentaren abonniert deren kostenlos
main kanal hier unter dem video files
noch kein teil der luke schulzeit und
jetzt kommt das auto
[Musik]
ein